[Music]
my name is grace I'm a cloud solutions
architect based out the London office
just in case there was any confusion
where I came from and I'm here to talk
to you about blending DCP security
controls when it comes to security there
can't seems to be two approaches
thinking about what your users are
allowed to do and also what's permitted
within your organization and then also
what protecting against threats and
concerns and the controls you need to do
approach there so as you would expect
with GCP we have a selection of controls
and these are just two subsets and
either the this talk is all about
demystifying how you can pick and choose
various controls to address the
particular use cases start enough with
the first one which is what can your
users do when it comes to permissions
I am dictates what your cue users can do
it dictate who can do what on which
resource but before I go and talk to you
about how you implement I am in GCP I
need to talk to you about the cloud
resource manager the cloud resource
manager allows you to map your
organization its hierarchical
organization so you can map your teams
or maybe how your applications are
configured to Mac to of GCP in the
context of this talk the thing is it
provides hierarchical attachment points
for permissions and organize earned
organization policies okay so coming
back to why I am when you defy it when
you use I am you have to create an IM
policy and IM policy you bind users to a
set permissions with set permissions are
called roles these are the users that
GCP recognizes but it doesn't preclude
you from bringing your own identity
along so you can use Active Directory
you can use out that so once you've
defined your policy you then need to
decide where on the hierarchy you need
to attach it so whether at the
organization level folder level the
folders have a collection
projects within them project or even at
the resource level themselves as on Prem
as on in DCPS and Prem you have a number
of privileged roles you know like your
super user accounts so these are the
ones that you really really need to give
lease privileges and restrict the number
of users who use them I have granted
them so the policy admin gives you that
that person who has a tax impact role
the ability to have an organisation
manager and policies all throughout the
organization the organization role add
me
it gives them the ability to create
custom roles that apply throughout the
organization and policy admin folder and
project owner a pretty self-evident so
what you need to do is you tend to you
need to think about what roles your
users actually have are you are they
central network of security teams what
what permissions do they don't need your
data scientists they don't have the same
permissions as your central teams and
network the security teams so you need
to think that through so input sir when
it comes to thinking about all of those
you need to then kind of take take a
path to implement that look at the
orchids look at your organizational
hierarchy do that mapping create that
first do the functional - oh I am man ok
so that's probably a spreadsheet where
you train ok I know these guys or these
girls need to be able to do that then
determine where you need to attach that
policy and you need to audit all of this
so this is going to be an underlying
theme the auditing and login ok so let's
just talk through an example so you can
understand how you and this actually
works so here we have a central security
and networking team in this organization
so they manage all the network and
security policies they've given each
team of developers of developers their
own project but they're not allowed to
make any changes to the network of
security control they are allowed to
spin up instances so before I go on to
look at the iron policies I just need to
introduce you to yet another
trol this is shared VPC this allows you
to define an RFC 1918 network a network
network which you can divide up into
subnets these subnets the service
projects are you the projects that you
have given to your developers can then
make use of so there are actually three
3-iron policies that you need for this
particular example there three because
they're attached to different levels in
the hierarchy and project
okay so I've just taught you through
some of these so the first one is
attached at the organization hierarchal
this is for the network and security
admins so there's two groups here the
network admins we've got managing all
the network controls and the security
teams that managing the security teams
it's all the security rule sorry okay
this is managing of the attach to the
organization level first of the
developer projects this is on the host
project they need to be granted network
user because they're going to be using
that subnet that you're going to give
them access to which is in the host
project okay so they need to have
network user in the host project as well
second one is that the service project
are you the project that they spin these
instance up in they also need network
user there as well and they also need
the ability to spin up in each decide me
okay
so blending them all together visually
you can see where the networking
security admins have access to manage
the shared VPC network in the host
project and you can see where the
developers can use the subnets that's
been a side to their project and then
they can manage the instances in their
project so looking at what your can do
users can do there's resource manager to
pick up give you the hierarchical
attachment points in central management
cloud I am for those granulated
permissions and shared VPC which allows
you to have distinct your network and
administration ok you'll see this slide
a lot it's just kind of give you a
reminder of where they where they're
coming from
logical groupings so this point I've
actually like to introduce Charlie from
verily who's going to explain to you how
they actually implement this within
their organization thanks charlie thank
you so much grace hi everyone
welcome I hope you I've enjoyed your
time at GCP next thus far my name is
Charlie Aronson and I'm a technical
program manager working on cloud data
security and verily life sciences and
alphabet company as you heard from Diane
and sundar yesterday at yesterday's
keynote googles mission is to organize
the world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful
well born out of alphabets moonshot
Factory Google X barely has the mission
to make the world's health information
useful so that people can enjoy
healthier lives as you might imagine
working towards this mission can often
take a number of forms and many times we
realize this mission through
partnerships for some of these
partnerships such as VirB focusing on
surgical robotics or on duo where we
work on evolving diabetes management GCP
and indeed G suite are at the core of
our collaboration in terms of working
together as well as developing together
in order to ensure that we're set up for
success when using GCP both internally
and indeed for these partnerships we've
developed and follow a few key
principles for cloud data security and
operations these are separable ax T we
need to ensure that there is a clear
differentiation in between different
project teams and their data
maintainability thinking through how our
systems are going to be used not just
today but for years to come and three
simplicity ensuring that we create and
advise the use of understandable
security configurations so as you can
and as you may imagine bringing these
principles into action often requires
that we blend a few different GC P and G
sweet tools and systems over the next
few minutes I'm gonna explain how we use
GCP hierarchy G Suite groups as well as
cloud Identity and Access Management I
am to accomplish and meet our principles
so let's start with separable 'ti we
need to ensure that our surgical
analytics data is entirely separate from
our baseline biological sample data we
do this by organizing our GCP hierarchy
into folders and then subfolders below
that and project below that that allows
as you can see on screen for us to
literally separate out the data and the
subsequent access ensuring that we
adhere to the separable 'ti principle
next comes maintainability we organize
our identities into groups then we
associate that are associated with a
specific role or project within the
organization so to give you a tangible
example think of allison and charlie who
are both software engineers on a given
project they're contained within a group
and then the great thing about this is
if we have another software engineer
join the team we just add her to the
group and she automatically has all the
access that she needs to do a role it's
a fantastic way to ensure that we
maintain the level of groups and access
that we need next rather than adding
individuals to resources we had these
groups to resources by either a canned
widely available or custom role this
allows us to focus on ensuring that we
gate access at the group level and make
sure that the appropriate people are in
the appropriate groups on a personal
note this has saved me an enormous
amount of time in troubleshooting access
requests and issues and is fundamental
to how we approach maintainability
finally comes simplicity by bringing
together these practices we work to
create a consistent understandable and
of course simple GCP access control
system at barelly we endeavor to use the
platform as intended rather than rolling
our own solutions and we are thoughtful
about our hierarchy and where we grant
groups access to resources
to ensure that we maintain of course the
appropriate access as well as the
appropriate separation in using the
platform as intended we often find areas
to give feedback to GCP and this is
fantastic our relationship with GCP has
been really collaborative and this is
not just because we ran out of a company
this is because GCP is all about
collaboration so I encourage you all go
ahead use your account teams your
support representatives or a product
form to ensure that you provide feedback
on how you're using the product to make
it better for all of us data security
and segmentation are of absolute
paramount importance to verily thus in
order to ensure that our teams and
collaborations are set up for success
we've developed principles which guide
our deployment of Google cloud platform
DCP at bearly I hope I've been able to
share some brief insights about how GCP
is helping us realize our mission of
making the world's health information
useful so that people can enjoy
healthier lives thank you all so much
and I'll pass you back to grace
thank you very much okay so continuing
on with the use cases number two looking
at enforcing what's not allowed there's
often be the case that you want to have
standard and controls that are spread
down throughout Europe but you want to
do this with it without getting in the
way of your developers you still want
them to be agile GCP has something
called organization policies so the
organization policy service it allows
you to provide standard controls that
provide enforcement throughout your
organization that you can override at
different levels okay so I'm just going
to keep it simple and then talk about
colors but you for every resource they
supported by organization policy there's
a list of constraints that tell you how
that resource can be restricted so in
this case we're looking at a resource
that's got four colors you may recognize
them and in the standard here is the
fact that you're only going to have two
colors as that standard colors that are
used within your organization so red and
green this is your standard but as ever
there's always exceptions so first group
says well okay we like to standard but
we also want to use blue so you just add
blue so you can augment it the other one
says well we don't want our team to be
able to use green quite like green
myself so they can only use red and then
the other two this standards aren't
actually applying at all so in this case
they've got an organization policy
that's defined at the folder level for
the first one which is just yellow and
the last group they're not having a
standards applied to them they can just
use whatever color they want so you can
see how you can be adaptable so you can
say set the standards but you can also
flex to meet the requirements okay so
all the policies and I for IOM policies
are orthogonal but slightly related so
all policies are all about how those
resources can be configured where as
iron policy is about who can
access those resources okay quite an
important distinction so moving on to
look at how you can protect your DCP
environment think of maybe like
preventing data exfiltration think of
that as being the use case as I walk
through this that was help okay so as
you'd expect there's a whole shopping
list of controls that you can use for
this particular use case I'm just going
to talk about some of the controls I
haven't already touched upon so let's
start with subnets subnets allow you to
define a logical decision in terms of
traffic okay you can actually use it to
kind of separate you know your database
back-end from your own application
middleware you can actually have
different teams working in different
subnets and you can use it whenever when
I say for hey CheY deployments is that
you can obviously have subnets within
different zones okay firewall the
firewall obviously helps you to manage
traffic between those subnets because
traffic by default doesn't them isn't
actually between the subnets unless you
explicitly define it
so the firewall is distributed it's set
up at the V PC network that you define
it it has you know as you'd expect
ingress and egress rules denying allow
rules one of the things that I really
really like about is the fact that you
can have a called rules so just to
understand that I'll just talk about
firewalls with looking at service
accounts to set up those rules it's a
service account sir one of the
identities I touched upon briefly at the
early on its the programmatic identity
for your BM or application so using
service accounts allows you to set up
firewall rules in terms of intent are
you rather than thinking about oh what's
the IP address of my web server or my
database you can think I want to allow
my web server to talk to my back-end
database it actually helps to mitigate
user error because you're thinking of
it's just more natural to think about it
in that form so it you know it's
authenticated rules and I'm you know
obviously I'm excite
and I really like it okay so moving on
just want to mention private google
access this enables your virtual
machines on a your what your subnets to
reach Google API endpoints such as
bigquery cloud storage via the Google
Network so you don't actually have to go
out to the public IP address okay to
supplement all those network controls we
have VPC service controls VPC service
control was allowed to provide a
perimeter boundary to complement those
controls so it's defense-in-depth
this isn't a replacement for any of
those it let it's there to help mitigate
data exfiltration risks like from
missing misconfigured I in policies
those things happens maybe you've to
make sure that you know that people who
are allowed to be access your projects
are allowed to access those project so
I've just go through a quick example so
you can visualize what this actually
means here we have the two projects that
are allowed to talk to communicate with
each other so you got the iron controls
you've got the firewall rules set up
between them but as you can see there
other paths in and out you can have you
know an unauthorized client might be
able to get to the data in your mgcp
service there it might look scary but we
have something to kind of alleviate that
pain service access zones so here you
can see that you provide this define its
perimeter you define things like from
trusted IP o I P arranges so if I talk
you through the unauthorized client its
if you can imagine that you've had some
sort of identity theft okay it's highly
unlikely that they are going to be using
that identity to access your protected
projects on that from your network so it
gives you a bit of time to mitigate the
actual theft of the identity in that way
as well you can actually prevent using
the zone you can actually define what
it's not allowed to talk to so you may
decide that these project
you don't want them to be able to write
data to another cloud storage bucket or
to bigquery outside of those projects so
it kind of keeps them keeps them kind of
covered up for you okay
so blending those together you have IM
for the granulated permissions you have
the set of network controls and then you
have B PC Service controls to complement
all of those okay so we've talked about
what your new users are allowed to do
then let's talk about what they're not
allowed to do the unauthorized access
you need to manage who has access you
need to understand your users so have a
central repack that sort of repos
probably the wrong word I have a sexual
identity store that you manage your erm
identities for so you can use cloud
identity or you can use them you know as
I said earlier you can use your own
identity store use groups as Charlie
just walked you through earlier the OS
login this allows you to tie in who has
ssh login to your your instances with
cloud identity so you're managing that
that centrally you give those users that
correct I am policy they're allowed to
actually ss-18 it's a central
administration so you're not worrying
about actually setting all that with a
random Keys being added two instances
are meta and a metadata use I am for
lease profit privilege stack driver
stack driver is it's important because
not your monitor your logs monitoring is
the first sign of any issues so abdomen
activity logs will tell you who's had
who's doing what who's made an access
call to it to particular source of
sources who started up that VM data
access logs who's had access to your
data you can use cloud I am to restrict
who can actually view those logs and
then you can do things like dashboards
you can export them to your own siem if
you want you can filter and obviously
you can alert on that service account
service accounts are the keys to your
door so you
to manage them properly okay if you if
you're running on GC GC GC u then we
manage the key rotation for you we
manage the rotation you don't don't need
to download them these the blast radius
is minimized we do understand that you
do need to download keys so even though
I say to avoid you download a production
key to absolutely understand that you
might have applications that are running
off prim that you want to access GC p
API endpoints if you do that you're
going to have to implement processes to
manage the downloaded keys use things
like tools various tools to like them to
check that your keys aren't them
upgraded to github okay restrict put in
policies the keys that expire quickly
minimize the radius and the possibility
use the key management service to
encrypt your config files and your
service account keys your service
account keys are secrets and then have a
process to unencrypted and use them and
gain audit usage so looking at that
unauthorized access again you number of
controls and this is just one way of
actually thinking of dealing this key
management service cloud I am and that
driver login okay so now we've talked
about managing and look at controlling
your GCP environment now let's think
about the fact of you know you're
running you're running an application on
GCP how you protect that so let's think
about a web facing application so again
another set of control that you can use
to apply to this use case starting off
with cloud load balancing we GCP has a
number of low cloud load balancing
options but for our use case an
application exposed to the Internet I'll
just focus on the global HTTP load
balancer when you're able to label the
HTTP load balancer Google infrastructure
mitigates absorbs many layer four and
below attacks such as syn floods IP
fragment floods and port exhaustion etc
it's generally used in conjunction with
managed instance groups management
oops allow you to define a number of
identically configured instances that
still scale up and down so it can absorb
your any attacks across those instances
if you so wish to okay in conjunction
with go below counter balancer we have
cloud armor okay let's similarly to the
global odor balancer that's a mouthful
it's it's distributed towards the edge
of Google's Network so it can absorb
attacks closest to the source it's based
on three three three main things it's
built on three pillars a policy
framework a rich rules language and
globally and it's a globe and the global
enforcement infrastructure it will help
you defend against DDoS attacks you can
define security policies you can do
white lists you can block block traffic
you can preview traffic it's a very
powerful tool that we've made available
to help you with your web facing
applications but it doesn't stop there
okay identity a web proxy this is
evolved from Google's beyond Corp it
allows users who've got the right iron
policies it will authenticate and
authorize access to your web facing
applications I'm showing it here working
with compute engine and kubernetes
engine it works pretty much the same
with App Engine okay it's
defense-in-depth though so don't forget
to set those terms that your firewall
rules are properly and don't forget to
make sure that your mitigate in any
unauthorized SSH access so we've talked
about your user authentication and
authorization the next thing you said is
what about your api's so and they API
proxy think about it is an abstraction
above your API layer
GCP has two types
it has a Cloud endpoints which is great
if your all your application is all in
on GCP it provides a management layer
and it will all say
take calls to the api's if however you
want more enterprise-e type features and
it's multi-platform
then Apogee API edge will be the one
that you should be looking at so I ap is
for your users and API proxies are for
your authentication of your api's and
your application code and you need to be
secure and you need to trust it ok so
use a security scanner the GCE and ji-ae
make sure your mitigate inferred the
oaep stop pain know your code so use
private source repos contain a registry
and contain a builder know what's in
your code that you're deploying so from
one end to the other is the identity of
a proxy for your users are accessing
cloud armor in conjunction with global
node balancer to to mitigate hail block
traffic and help mitigate and DDoS
attacks and then api proxies for your
api's alright so finally in not least I
just want to talk about watching that
what's going on so monitoring alert in a
faucet so as you expect we've got a
collection of tools again and as before
I'm just going to talk about the ones
that I haven't already spoken about so
let's just have a quick look at VPC
float logs so there was a great talk
yesterday for - the PM so if you didn't
catch it then really go and watch it on
youtube all about VPC flow logs they
allow you to get Network telemetry for
to and from your VMs rather within DCP
or whether it's coming from with the
internet go into your VMs
it allows you to it can it's useful for
forensics and security analyses you can
export to an S I am you confuse the you
can view this telemetry data within
stackdriver so you can export to any of
the sinks that stackdriver supports like
bigquery and cloud storage cloud
security command center this gives you a
single pane of glass ok it gives you a
picture
security slanted picture of your own
resources it's modular okay it gives you
an asset discovery in infantry what's
really cool about the intra infantry you
know you're working in the cloud so
you're gonna be scaling up and down
there might have been you know for some
you know there might have been some
instances in the past they've been used
to do you know Bitcoin mining that's a
big thing at the moment those were spun
up then spun down you can still have
insights into those spun down or
destroyed instances okay that's kind of
a really nice feature of the cloud
security content it got lots of other
nice features but that's the one that
I've really really loved it integrates
with the data loss prevention API data
loss prevention API allows you to
classify your data for classify your
sensitive data if you want more
information about that there is the
showcase where the DLP engineers are
hanging around cloud security scanner to
scan your applications it allows you to
integrate with third-party tools as well
and it gives you notifications so for
sexy is one of those tools that
integrates with for SETI's open source
security talk tooling that's involved
from GTP's into develop from Google's
internal tooling it's a community driven
it's open source takes pull requests it
gives you an inventory it allows you to
enforce firewall rules so if first
sample you have a standard that says
this is the firewall rules I want to
apply somebody sets it back for SETI
will actually reset that for you I am
explaining is really kind of cool
because that gives you an understand the
impact of your IM policies
so therefore fleshie guides are also
around here as well so blending that
together VPC flow logs for your network
telemetry cloud security control close
command center for your single pane of
glass so that driver login for who did
what where and wane and for the alerts
okay so i'd now like to introduce Arthur
from verily who's going to talk to you
about how they watched their watch
what's going on thanks Arthur
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Arthur and I'm a
software engineer at verily life
sciences I work closely with charlie
building the services tolling and
scripting to keep our healthcare data
secure
so my section of the talk will be diving
into the weeds a little bit on specific
things that we've done to abide by best
practices to keep the data as secure as
possible so there will be three big
principles that we speak about today one
is how to generate persist and
reasonably analyze your audit logs to
look at who is accessing what data and
security configurations to is looking at
how to reasonably perform org-wide I am
policy reviews you need to know what's
in your policies to make sure that
they're secure and third is how you can
perform company-wide two rollouts and
patches in the event that there's a
security vulnerability that you've
identified so we'll first dive into
logging in healthcare this is something
that we're legally required to do for
the most sensitive types of data and
it's generally a best practice that we
should all be doing and there's some
questions that you may want to ask for
example for a particular piece of
sensitive data who all or what are all
the identities that have accessed that
piece of data second you may want to
look at who is setting security
configurations in your project in the
event that something was opened up to
widely and third is you may want to do
diligence on a particular employee and
ask what are every piece of data or
every security configuration update that
you know so-and-so has done at your
company those are questions you may ask
so there's three big things that you
need to guarantee when using Google
cloud platform to make sure that you can
answer these questions reliably number
one is you need to turn on your audit
logs by default your security
configuration update logs are on but
your data read and data write logs are
not on for projects so it's imperative
that you set these on at the project
level I on policy and that you also
we'll talk about this a little bit more
downstream but that you check that
they're never flipped off ephemerally
second is that you need
to export your logs now the natural
place that someone may try to export the
logs is within the project for which the
logs are being generated however we'll
we'll talk here shortly on why that's a
very bad idea actually you may export
your logs through a couple of different
services on GC p GC s exports to json
it's great for data robustness not the
best for doing analysis on your logs
they also export to bigquery which is
our preference and probably the easiest
place to really dive into those logs and
then if you need to build some real-time
business logic on top of your audit logs
you can also export to cloud pub/sub now
the reason that i was speaking of
earlier on why not to create a bigquery
data set in a project itself for which
the logs are going to be dumped too is
because oftentimes we set wide access
rules at the project level
I am policy and I am is fundamentally
hierarchical so for example if you use
project editor bigquery data set editor
bigquery admin storage object admin
storage object delete permissions you're
going to be giving a potentially wide
group of people access to permanently
delete your audit logs with no means of
reproducing them and if you're in the
business of health care that's something
that we absolutely cannot have so
instead we've adopted a different best
practice which is to export logs into a
company-wide project where no individual
has 24/7 access to this project and we
can ensure that our logs are never
deletable by the teams for which we want
to be auditing another key detail on
this slide is that you can see and
charlie spoke a little bit more about
this earlier we are pretty heavily using
cloud folders to segregate different
clusters of projects into different
hierarchical paths and this is very nice
because now cloud folders has a feature
where you can turn on audit logging for
all children so as long as the projects
are generating the logs and the folder
export is configured appropriately you
can have strong guarantees that every
single audit log underneath some parent
label or a parent fold
we'll be exported somewhere and for us
we actually have one-to-one parity
between our cloud folders and our
bigquery datasets in a company-wide
super privileged project and this will
come into handy later okay so the third
principle with audit logs is that people
need to actually look at them or you
need to run automated jobs to check for
specific things for example who all has
changed your project level i''m policy
in the last month who what individual
non service accounts have accessed data
that should never be accessed by humans
and the way that we've configured things
that you saw in the last slide is that
because there's this one-to-one parity
between a cloud folder and a bigquery
data set you can simply grant access to
whatever groups have break glass access
or super admin access or tl access on
the the cluster of projects to their own
audit logs with bigquery data set viewer
so that they can read the logs and
bigquery job user so that they can
actually run queries against them this
ensures that they can look at their logs
but also ensures that your logs will
never be deleted and you won't be liable
for that as a company okay
second big topic for the day is looking
at how we can perform I am security
audits in some specific use cases for
that going back to the previous slide if
we look at the clusters of folders we
can imagine that if a TL is responsible
for some cluster whether it's the data
warehouse the you know the front-end
serving app the replicas in in one
folder they want to be able to look at
every single iam policy or some ion
policy digest for their set of projects
specific things you may want to check is
that an identity outside of your
organization does not have access to
sensitive information so for example if
if you're a company that hires a
consultant and you decide to use that
consultants at gmail.com address and at
some point the deal is done and you want
to remove their access and this can
actually be a very complicated project
you can't simply delete their account
because it may be their personal Gmail
so instead you need to scrape every
policy recursively and delete them and
the only really way
to guarantee that is via this I think
the folder structure and recursively
crawling down and updating the item
policies second big thing is you may
want to do routine audits to make sure
that only robot identities have access
to some of the sensitive data in your
project so white lists specific buckets
specific datasets specific sequences and
ensure that no one's granted themselves
access to look at it third is as we were
talking about earlier you have to make
sure that all of your projects have
audit logging on and then this is never
turned off by a user so we should be
auditing this and forth and this is a
problem that's plagued pretty much all
of the cloud providers instead there's a
feature on GCS buckets and bigquery
datasets where you can make the data
within them readable to the entire world
without requiring any authorization it's
great for global research collaborations
but you need to make sure it's never on
your most sensitive projects so we
apparently have some very robust tooling
around this to make sure that it will
never happen to us okay third topic that
we want to talk about today is how to
perform company-wide rollouts in cases
of time-sensitive emergencies again the
the folder structures really paramount
to performing this so for example one
use case we had which is the first one
listed there was there were three times
in 2017 where we needed to patch every
single VM in the company due to bugs
like the the global spectra bug which
are bugs that affect the the OS machines
that Google doesn't control for your VMs
and to orchestrate this smoothly the
client is actually responsible for
rebooting and patching every VM because
Google is not going to randomly turn
down your machines it could a [ __ ]
affect production access so by having
the cloud folders we were able to look
at all the folders that don't serve
production traffic immediately roll out
a job to reboot and patch their VMs and
then go team by team for ones that did
production traffic and with the consent
of their TLS recursively reboot all
their VMs for them and as a result we as
a company we're able to reboot thousands
of VMs in a couple of hours whereas if
you don't have this structure it would
be a nightmare to even track down the
VMS in the first place second case where
this is particularly useful is because
we have a service account with super
admin access at the top we can pretty
easily add people in as long as there's
a couple approvals to grant break glass
access to for example security engineers
that find some mission-critical
configuration issue or other people on a
team in the event that the TL forgot -
you know set up the on-call group
appropriately and we need to give
someone access to the project and the
third example here which we talked about
earlier was being able to quickly crawl
your entire GCP universe and remove a
specific identity from all access okay
so at this point I'd like to hand it
back to grace and we spoke a little bit
about how barelly uses the best of GCP
to secure our hyper sensitive data Thank
You grace thank you offer
okay just to wrap up and then there's a
Q&A so just a checklist you need to
define when you start off thinking about
what controls you need define what your
users should be able to do think about
those controls the I am at functional
map think about what's not allowed
organization policy and then think about
what you're trying to guard and protect
against okay what are the threats what
are your concerns
choose your controls from the shopping
list remember these are just a subset
and I've just kind of put them into a
logical order blend those controls
together the third defense index
approach and monitor all the things
[Music]